[Music]
do you remember the time when conspiracy
theorists were seen as weirdos Freaks
and outcasts who spent their time
borrowing deeper and deeper into weird
online conspiracies as a way to
compensate for the fact they've never
had sex and practically every conspiracy
ended with and we all know who's behind
it the Jews it was a fun game for all
the family to play especially if your
life isn't turning out quite the way you
hoped you desperately need someone to
blame and you have German ancestors my
favorite conspiracy is the great
replacement which believes that Jewish
people were importing millions of
Muslims to Europe because they wanted to
get rid of white people because that's
what Jewish people want to be surrounded
by Muslims the Middle East has been a
global success story for all involved
and there's never been a crossw between
the two sides not even even a
microaggression you can see that the
people dreaming up these conspiracies
aren't exactly the brightest Minds
anyway it's now
2024 and if you're not a conspiracy
theorist you're pretty much in the
minority brexit Trump covid Hunter
Biden's laptop the Twitter files and
spending every waking hour online has
turned our brain into mush and we've all
slid down our own unique internet rabbit
holes and some of us just keep sliding
because as any six-year-old will tell
you going down a slide is great fun and
what else are we meant to do now that
we're all working from home do some work
no thank you that's why we work from
home to be fair it's not like the
authorities aren't fueling that
particular fire whether it's certain
states trying to stop Trump from running
or the whole Epstein Scandal the
business we all need to get into is
selling tinfo hats and invest investing
in forchan but the story of Jeffrey
Epstein is my favorite conspiracy theory
in that none of it makes sense how did
he make the money how did he connect
with all these famous people how did he
continue to hang out with them long
after he was convicted of being a sex
offender how did he manage to escape
prosecution for so long despite having a
pedophil sex ring in the Virgin Islands
the Virgin Islands isn't that the worst
place to host that type of crime
wouldn't that be like me cheating on my
wife in the Essex Village of fingering
ho talk about hiding in plain sight
everything about the case feels like it
was made up by a 15-year-old boy who has
an overactive imagination and just
discovered weed for the first time
pedophiles royalty disabled Geniuses and
presidents all it needs is some kind of
alien abduction with the gram reveal
being that the aliens were Jews all
along and we'd have a full house now the
truth is if you've been following
following this story none of the names
will come as a surprise Trump Steven
Hawkin prince Andrew Alan duritz Bill
Clinton the list goes on and on but it
doesn't make it any less fun who doesn't
want to know that prince Andrew is
mentioned 67 times in the epin files 67
times I don't think my mother has
mentioned my name 67 times except to
call me up and tell me how disappointed
she is in me I'm 41 years old unmarried
and still a comedian the only people
that she thinks do less work than
comedians are the royal family this is
of course incredibly unfair because
judging by the revelations prince Andrew
has an incredible dedication to his
craft Bill Clinton was another
well-known individual who was outed we
all know that bill was good mates with
Epstein Jeffrey even had this painting
of Bill in his house now some of you may
find this disturbing but I salute
Jeffrey for his commitment to diversity
equity and inclusion by including a
trans version of Bill Clinton all we
need to make this totally Progressive is
for someone to do an Instagram post
about it write the words yes Queen and
put some fire emojis underneath it the
allegations against Clinton are very
serious with Epstein saying that bill
like them young this is awful and I need
to make it absolutely clear for legal
reasons and also so that I don't suffer
the same fate as Jeffrey and kill myself
that nothing has been proven against
Bill Clinton the allegations are very
serious but this is all they are
allegations having said that I still
wouldn't trust Bill to babysit my nieces
anytime soon and yet he'd still make for
a better president than Joe Biden and be
less divisive than Donald Trump trump
was another person who knew Epstein and
was quoted as saying I've known Jeff for
15 years terrific guy he's a lot of fun
to be with it is even said that he likes
beautiful women as much as I do and many
of them are on the younger side no doubt
about it Jeffrey enjoys his social life
it's not the best Trump impression but
it's what you're given deal with it
admittedly Trump said this in 2002 many
years before Jeffrey's first convictions
it still feels really dodgy
though it's a bit like me praising a
young Bill Cosby for knowing how to make
women feel
relaxed and that isn't even the most
interesting thing about the case after
epin was arrested there was the suicide
now this is where I go full conspiracy
theorists and say I don't think he
killed himself the guardian his high
security prison cell Were Meant to check
up on him every half hour they didn't
despite him being placed on suicide
watch medical experts have said that the
bones that were broken in Epstein's neck
were a broken hyoid bone now these bones
can be broken in many circumstances but
is more commonly associated with
homicidal strangulation than suicidal
hanging Epstein regularly stated that he
wouldn't kill himself as he was a coward
the whole thing smells a little bit like
a coverup maybe he didn't kill himself
but it sounds a hell of a lot more
plausible than Jews are trying to fill
London with Muslims because they prefer
to be surrounded by people called
Muhammad instead of Chris one of the
positives of this whole Grizzly Saga is
that in a world that gets more divided
by the hour Epstein's death brought us
together as we all knew that he
definitely didn't kill himself finally a
subject gender critical feminist guno IM
Maga supporters gender fluid interex
progressives and Nick Fuentes could all
see eye to eye on that is a one thing
that even Owen Jones and Adolf Hitler
would agree on that and needing to see
more evidence about the war crimes
committed by Hamas on October the 7th
the story of Epstein's island has only
taught us one thing you can't trust
anyone not the media not the government
not the justice system there's only one
person you can trust that one mate of
yours who smokes too much weed never had
a job and thinks that a group of satanic
pedophiles runs a world turns out he was
right all along sorry
Dave before you go let me take a minute
to recommend a longevity supplement by
Versa in our recent interview with Tim
Urban he said we should be talking about
longevity and Longevity science
researchers like the biologist David
Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that's why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
in your body now NAD is arguably the
most important molecule in your body
high NAD levels improve your metabolism
repairs damage DNA and increases energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
this video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join me you can get
15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use code trigger to save 15% off
your order
[Music]
yeah